You're so you're a Muslim.
>> What's up? Welcome. Welcome. Yes. My
name is Manari.
>> Okay.
>> God logic. What's What's the whole
argument? I'm trying to understand what
the argument is. The argument is the
Muslims follow the Bible. Is that the
whole argument?
>> The argument is that the Quran says that
the Bible is the authority over the
Quran.
>> And you you got that from the claim the
people of the book. I got it from the
claim that Muhammad has to uh go to the
previous scriptures if he's doubting the
Quran.
>> Okay. And then did you read the claim
afterwards and did you read the verse
before?
>> Yeah.
>> Because the verses basically proclaim
that he's never going to need to go to
any other scripture. For example, and do
not be one of the one of those who deny
Allah's signs or you will be one of the
losers. That's literally the next
passage. So,
>> so could that be that he's asking him,
hey, if you if you don't like our
religion, why don't you go back to these
other religions? And
>> he says, if you're doubting the
revelation that we've given you, then go
ask the people who've been reading the
scripture before you, be not of those
who doubt. So, basically, he's saying if
if there's a case that he's he's
doubting the Quran, he can go check the
previous scriptures and see that what
he's receiving is true.
>> Okay. And where can we go ahead and
check the previous scriptures? The
Torah, the gospel, and the songs.
>> The Torah, the gospel, and the songs. Do
those exist? First of all, did those
those are not dimensions? My
understanding was only the Torah and the
Injil. There was never a mention of the
Psalms. Is the angel the Psalms?
>> Psalms. The Psalms of David, the Zabore.
>> Oh, Psalms. Okay. Okay. Okay. Sure.
Sure. So, where can we find those script
scriptures?
>> They're in the Bible.
>> Yeah. But the Bible, we already you
already agree with me, has been
completely corrupted. So, we cannot
sure. Who's the author of of Who's the
author of Psalm? I don't agree with you
on that. Nor
>> Okay, who's the who's the author of my
honor? Hold on a second. I don't agree
with you on that. Nor does your Quran
agree with you on that. But let's even
let's say I even grant you that
position.
>> I don't I'm asking you what do
Christians think is the who's the writer
of
>> Manar goodness relax. So based on the
verse, we clearly see that it's the
previous scriptures that are the
authority over the Quran, right?
>> How from this one verse? Do you have any
other verses? Well, all you need is this
verse. Well, there's other verses. Yes.
But from this verse is what I'm
specifically talking about. From this
verse, we see clearly 1094 that Muhammad
that the previous scriptures are the
authority over the Quran. Right.
>> Okay. So, I'll read the verse so we are
clear on this. This is the verse you're
talking about. If you, oh prophet, are
in doubt about those these stories or
those stories that we have revealed to
you, then ask those who read the
scripture before you. The truth the
truth has certainly come to you from
your Lord. So do not be one of those who
doubt. That's the one you're talking
about.
>> Yep.
>> So this verse is the single-handed verse
that made you not, this is not a
conspiracy theory. This is completely
you using this verse to come up with a
conclusion that Muslims use the Bible
and the Torah to come up with their
conclusions.
>> I'm saying that the Quran here is saying
that the previous scriptures are used to
verify the Quran, not the other way
around. So look, it's it's like this. If
Muhammad doubts the Quran, Allah tells
him, "Go check the previous scriptures."
If you're doubting the Quran, because
why? Because they're going to confirm
what he's saying. So if Muhammad's
doubting the Quran, he can go check the
previous scriptures and he'll see that
if what he's receiving lines up with the
previous scriptures, he'll know that
what he's receiving is actually true. If
what he's receiving does not line up
with the previous scriptures, then he'll
know that what he's receiving is false.
does or or or I'm sorry could this be
for example an explanation like can we
interpret it in this way that if prophet
Muhammad did go and try to understand it
from the previous scriptures then God
would have basically undermined him and
throw him out of his uh care for example
because the next verse says and do not
be one of those who deny Allah's signs
or you will be one of the loser so why
would he ask him hey if if oh prophet if
you're in doubt why don't you go read
those stories of the other books and
then the next verse tell him and if you
didn't have any doubt then do not then
you're going to be one of the losers.
>> No. Well, it says do not deny his signs
and you'll be one of the losers
>> or you will be one of the losers. And
okay, so this is the this is the actual
verse. This is 94 says if you prophet
are in doubt about these stories. Okay.
So would you agree that these stories
can also be another word for signs.
>> Sure. So if the ne the verse 94 says if
you oh prophet are in doubt about these
signs we can say that let's paraphrase
these signs that we have revealed to you
then go ask the people of the scripture
before you and then the next verse says
and if you and and do not be one of
those who deny Allah's signs or you will
be one of the losers that means if you
deny the sign and you go ask the people
of the scriptures before you will be one
of the losers. Isn't that something we
can interpret from this?
>> No he doesn't say if you go ask then
you'll be one of the losers. If he deni
see the verse stop
>> verse 94 is an evidence for the
revelation of the of of the Quran. It's
a it's an evidence of the signs that's
being of the signs being said. So after
and so go check the previous scriptures.
They're in line with each other. So you
have no reason to doubt. Then after that
it says so then if you deny his signs
you'll be of those who be of the losers.
So it gives you you can even go check
the previous scriptures you'll see that
in the lines you shouldn't doubt but
even after that if you still doubt and
deny the signs you're amongst the losers
you have me you want me to read this
verse literally or figuratively how do
you want me to read cuz when I read it
literally do you disagree with me that
the interpretation when you add it with
the next verse look how it says look how
it comes out it says if you oh prophet
are in doubt about these stories that we
have revealed to you then ask those who
read the scripture before you The truth
has certainly come to you from your
Lord. So do not be one of those who
doubt right after. Okay? So basically if
you're a doubter, go talk to the people
of the book because God does not lie.
Okay? And do not be one of the doubters.
Right? After it says the next verse, it
said, "And do not be one of those who
deny Allah." So do not be a so do not be
one of the those who doubt and do not be
one of those who deny Allah deny Allah's
signs or you will be one of the losers.
That means he's not even allowed to
question the stories and go back. You
understand what's happening here? He's
not allowed to go back to the old
scriptures.
>> He's not.
>> No, because if he does, let me finish
God logic, please. 10 more seconds. If
he does go back to the old scriptures,
it would prove that he is in doubt of
God. And if he proves that he's in doubt
of God, then he proves he's one of the
losers. Do you understand what's
happening here? You misunderstood,
misinterpreted the verses because you
didn't read the one after and the one
before.
>> Here's the one after it. Go ahead and
read that on the on the page. What does
it say?
>> Okay, read the one f the first one and
then read the one after.
>> We already did this one. Read this,
please.
>> Yeah. And never be one of those who deny
the signs of Allah. So he says if you're
uh if you are sign but never be one of
the deny.
>> Slow down. Slow down. Does it say deny
or does it say doubt
>> and never those who deny the signs.
>> Is denying not doubting. It says if he
has doubt it tells him what to do. So
even after he has doubts, this is what
it says. If he has doubts, if you are
doubt in doubt, ask those who read the
scripture before you, don't be those of
doubt of those who doubt and never deny,
never be of those who deny the signs of
a law. Period. So all of this is giving
you, it's you have no reason to deny or
to doubt the signs of a law. They line
up with what came before it. You have no
reason to doubt. There's the proof. The
proof is in that you can go ask the
people who've been reading the scripture
before you. That's the proof. So if you
even do this and you deny, then you're
amongst the losers.
>> So let me let me understand this. So if
you're in doubt, you're not denying.
>> No, I can I can have doubt on something
without denying it fully.
>> So if I have doubt of the Christian
faith, what does that mean?
>> It means that you have questions. It
means that there's something in you that
that you
>> could lead to denial. Could it lead?
>> It can lead to denial or you can get
your doubts clarified.
>> Okay. So, so basically what you're
saying is but the idea is so I'm trying
to understand here. So the argument is
that if you are a Muslim you need to go
to the Bible. Is this the argument here?
>> Well, yeah. That that that's
>> the only way you can become a Muslim is
if you read the Bible.
>> That's not what I said. Manar,
>> what's the argument?
>> Focus on what I'm saying. I'll give you
the argument one more time. You ready?
Let me know when you're ready. You
ready?
Okay. Here's the argument. The Quran
says in 1094 that the previous
scriptures are the authority over the
Quran. That's my argument.
>> And so I I would say this is a
misinterpretation of this uh verse. This
doesn't
>> So let's break it down then. So if
Muhammad has doubts about the Quran,
what does Allah tell him to do?
>> Go to the go read the scripture. But
he's not do you understand? He's not
allowed to have doubt because if he
didn't have doubt, he would be one of
the losers. for a second. So if he had
doubts about the Quran, Allah tells him
to go to the previous scriptures.
>> Can I ask you a question?
>> If he goes to the previous scriptures,
Manar, if he goes to the previous
scriptures, then it would clarify the
doubts that he has about the Quran,
right?
What previous scriptures? Which ones are
you talking about? If you're going to
>> Are you talking about the today's Bible,
King James version? Are we talking about
King James version?
>> Waste my time. Then I'm just
>> logic. No, no. I'm talking about which
which scripture is is this even? and
answer the question.
>> The problem is the problem is you have
one ver out of here.